Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ja, es gibt wieder verschiedene Chaos-Veranstaltungen, auf die wir gerne hinweisen werden. Es kommt also jetzt der Werbeblock, jetzt am Wochenende in Dresden, das ist ja sozusagen Vorort von Brandenburg, finden die Datenspuren statt. Dort in der Scheune in Dresdener Neustadt. Ja, und da gibt es so verschiedene Themen, Vorträge und Workshops, die alle was mit dem Netz zu tun haben, eben auch mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Netzzensur und so. Also das dürfte sehr interessant werden. Eintritt ist frei bzw. wird um Spenden gebeten. Außerdem gibt es wieder Datengärten in Berlin, im Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11, nämlich am 8. Oktober erzählt Erdgeist zusammen mit anderen was über OpenTracker. Und am 22. Oktober gibt es von Henry Story, das ist ein Gast aus Amerika, der gerade in Berlin ist, etwas über selbstgebasselte Social-Web-Systeme, also auch ganz interessant. Und dann gibt es natürlich zum Jahresende wieder den Kongress, den Chaos Communication Kongress im Berliner Kongresszentrum vom 27. bis 30. Dezember und das Motto...
Und noch einen ganz kleinen Termin, den sich so am Rande mitbekommen haben. Am Sonntag ist Chaos Radio Hörer-Treffen.
Das ist fast wie Chat-Treffen.
So sieht's aus.
Dann müssen wir da mal hin.
Kann man ja auch mal machen. So, das sind die Termine, die gibt's auch bestimmt noch mal online nachzulesen. Auf welcher eurer zahlreichen Internetseiten?
Zum Beispiel auf berlin.cde. Da gibt's dann auch gleich eine Unterseite mit Terminen, aber auf der Startseite steht's auch schon.
Alles klar, da könnt ihr noch mal nachklicken. Wir reden jetzt über Netzneutralität. Es geht darum, wie das Netz die Art behandelt, die ihr da durchschicken wollt. Ob es sagt, hey, ist mir egal, was du machst, ich mach das alles gleich schnell. Oder ob es sagt, oh, du machst gerade Dateien austauschen. Ach nö, das lassen wir mal lieber, mach mal ein bisschen langsamer. Martin hat eine Frage dazu, ob ein bestimmtes Ding, von dem er gehört hat, auch zu dem Thema Netzneutralität gehört. Hallo Martin.
Hi, und zwar gab es ja dieses Urteil in Frankreich, wo jemand komplett vom Internet ausgeschlossen wurde, weil er, glaube ich, Feilscheren übertrieben hat. Woll mich mal interessieren, ob das nicht auch irgendwie zum Thema Netzneutralität gehört, weil es ja für jeden nutzbar sein sollte.
Natürlich, also das ist kein Urteil, das war jetzt ein Gesetz, was verabschiedet worden ist, in dem eine Three-Strikes-Out-Regelung verabschiedet worden ist. Das heißt, wenn du dreimal beim Feilscheren aufgefallen bist, dann wird dir der Netzzugang einfach abgeknapst. Und das ist natürlich das ganz krasse Extrem zur Netzneutralität, wenn du einfach schlicht und klar kein Internet mehr zu Hause hast und gar nicht mehr am Internet teilnehmen kannst, weil du einfach dein Recht auf freien Datenaustausch im Netz wahrgenommen hast.
Und dem Provider wechseln hilft nicht oder so eine Scherzfin?
Nein, du kommst dann in eine Datenbank, da hat auch ein Richter dort entschieden und der macht, dass du nicht mehr am Internet teilnehmen darfst.
Also quasi liegen meine Daten bei jedem Provider vor. Sobald mein Name da irgendwie in der Datenbank auftaucht, leuchtet die rote Lampe und das heißt, der darf kein Internet haben.
Denen wird da schon was einfallen. Ich glaube, über die Details müssen wir uns da jetzt gar nicht ergehen, sondern es ist eigentlich das Prinzip, was da so pervers ist, dass einfach dort Menschen ein Sinnesorgan abgeschnitten wird. Das ist einfach eine Amputation, weil heutzutage natürlich das Internet einfach dein zusätzlicher Sinn ist, den der moderne Mensch hatte. Den kann man nicht einfach abtrennen, ohne wie schwere Schäden so hinterlassen.
Noch dazu ist die Frage, wie will man dem Nutzer nachweisen, dass er Firesharing betrieben hat. Das ist heutzutage schon so, dass es mehr als dürftig ist, was da als Beweise vorgelegt wird. Und wenn drei ausreichen, um einem das Internet auszumachen, das sind irgendwie drei E-Mails von einer Anwaltskanzlei, die sich da Ausbildungen hat, für Rechteinhaber mehr zu verschicken.
Es geht nicht so einfach. Es muss ein Richterentscheid gefällt werden. Das heißt, es wird da richtig verhandelt und so. Und dann wird das Internet gesperrt. In Frankreich ist halt alles ein bisschen kontrollierter als hier. Ich habe das selber erlebt. Ich war vor einiger Zeit als Gast an der Uni in Frankreich. Und da habe ich eben so das normale Internet genießen dürfen, was man da so als Student und so genießen kann. Und auch als Mitarbeiter. Ja, und da gibt es halt nur Port 80. Also ich kann gerade mal im Internet surfen und sonst geht gar nichts. Also es ist nichts anderes, steht zur Verfügung. Das gab es allerdings.
Also reden wir jetzt von dem Netzwerk innerhalb der Uni?
Ja, wenn ich in der Uni, vom Campus aus, in so einem Pool ins Internet will, dann geht halt nur das. Oder auch mit meinem Rechner. Den kann ich überall anstöpseln, das geht halt schon, in der Bibliothek und so. Aber dann kriege ich halt wirklich nur eben Port 80 und eben auch 443.
Also das heißt normale Webseite aufrufen?
Normale Webseite.
Gibt es irgendeinen Grund, wie ihr einen Internetkurs, sag ich mal, von der Regierung aus vertreten oder rechtfertigen?
Ja, da gab es heute sogar ein Statement von der Bundesnetzagentur, die sich zu Netzneutralität bekannt hat im Rahmen des Eco-Kongresses. Nee, gestern war das, 29. Star ist auf Haise. Eco-Kongress, Bundesnetzagentur bekennt sich zur Netzneutralität, weil die natürlich auch die Debatte in den USA beobachtet haben, wo das mit der Netzneutralität schon so ein bisschen weiter und auch teilweise in den Mainstream-Medien ist, weil da große Netzbetreiber von so Diensten wie Amazon oder Google angefangen haben, sozusagen Datenmaut zu verlangen. Und ja, also da gibt es schon ein freundliches Statement, dass das ganz gut ist, dass diese Debatte mal anfängt und dass man sich damit mal auseinandersetzt mit dieser Netzneutralität.
Nun weiß man nicht, wie es in Deutschland weitergeht, ne? Also wir haben im Augenblick eine Regierungskoalition, von der die eine Hälfte das Netz vom Schmutz befreien will und die andere das Netz zum großen Geschäftsmodell ausbauen will. Und das ist eigentlich eine schwierige Kombination, wenn es um Netzneutralität geht.
Aber jetzt direkt, wie die Franzosen sozusagen ihre Netzpolitik vertreten und warum das so rechtlich fertig ist, ich meine jemanden vom Internet loszustöpseln, ich habe so einen Urteil schon gefallen, ist für irgendjemand, ist ja schon ein krasser Eingriff in das Menschenrecht.
Letztendlich resultiert das aus der Diskussion mit den Urhebern, also Musikindustrie, Filmindustrie, die es halt gerne hätten, dass sowas nicht mehr illegal runtergeladen wird. Das ist natürlich auch eine Form von Netzneutralität, könnte man sagen. Aber da sind wir dann quasi wieder beim Thema Urheberrecht und das wäre dann wieder ein anderes Chaosradio, mal gucken, wann das wieder dran ist. Martin, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und einen schönen Abend noch. Und dann haben wir einen anderen Martin und der hat sozusagen einen Vorschlag, wie man das lösen könnte mit der Netzneutralität. Hallo!
Ja, hallo.
So, erzähl mal, wie würdest du es machen?
Also das Thema ist ja gar nicht mal so uninteressant und zwar könnte man für verschiedene Usergruppen, nicht jedes Thema ist gleich interessant und zwar, keine Ahnung, der Musikliebhaber, den könnte man anbieten, dass der superschnell seine Musik bei, keine Ahnung, bei iTunes runterladen kann oder dass der Spieler seinen Anschluss extra vorkonfiguriert wird, damit er superschnell spielen kann, damit er jedem immer einen perfekten Ping hat oder so, keine Ahnung und das halte ich für gar nicht mal so eine schlechte Idee, aber naja, hat auch immer die ganze Sache immer auf den Haken gehemmt.
Na du würdest aber sagen, es wäre okay, wenn man sich den Internetanschluss zulegt, dann kann man halt ankreuzen, ich möchte Videofilme gucken und spielen und dann sagt der Internetanbieter, okay, das kostet dann so und so viel und wenn man halt ein komplett freies Internet haben will, dann wird das halt richtig teuer einfach.
Ja, das soll man immer abwägen, also wie viel bezahlt man jetzt momentan für einen sozusagen noch, ich weiß ja nicht, ob das jetzt schon gemacht wird, so wie ich das gehört hab, ja, ungefähr wahrscheinlich 30 Euro im Monat für einen Internetanschluss und wenn der dann plötzlich für einen ungefiltert ist und plötzlich 50 Euro bezahlen soll, dann würde ich das nicht eingehen.
Du meinst also, dass man für ein neutrales Netz einen gewissen Grundbetrag bezahlt und wenn man dann diese Netzneutralität nicht möchte, sondern bestimmte Dienste bevorzugt, einen kleinen Obolus oben drauf legen?
Ja genau, so wie das z. B mit dem Fastpass war, was ja jetzt bei Telekom ja weggefallen ist, für die kleineren Anschlüsse, dass man dann eben so 5 Euro bezahlt, damit man dann eben so eine Option wieder hat, damit eben Spiele schneller laufen oder Downloads nicht gedrosselt werden oder einer, der viel uploadet ins Internet sozusagen auf seine eigene Seite oder so. Dass der da nicht eingeschränkt wird, so was könnte man ja dann machen.
Jetzt sagt im Chat gerade jemand, naja, aber dann müsste man dem Internetprovider quasi verraten, was man so vorhat im Internet. Dann müsste man wieder ganz schön viel über sich verraten.
Das wäre dir aber egal.
Ja gut, also über illegale Aktivitäten, da brauchen wir ja nicht überreden.
Vielleicht gibt es so eine Extra-Checkliste auf dem Internetformular, so ich würde gerne illegale Musik runterladen.
Das ist eine Unerwünscht.
Muss ja nicht immer illegal sein. Es gibt ja auch durchaus...
Aber für dich wäre es halt eine Lösung, dass man sagt, hier ihr kriegt alles selbe Internet, wenn ihr extra wollt, könnt ihr extra bezahlen.
Das ist ein Ansatz, den man da vielleicht machen könnte, aber generell so was einfach so von heute auf morgen zu machen, ohne vielleicht seine keine Ahnung, seine Nutzer mal zu fragen, wie sie es gerne hätten, das wäre dann vielleicht schon mal ganz schön.
Alles klar, Martin, vielen Dank. Man könnte ja schon verschiedene Preismodelle machen, aber vorher sollten die großen Firmen mal ihre Nutzer fragen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wann das passiert.
Naja, das mit dem Nutzerdialog und den Netzbetreibern, das hat man ja am Chaoses Vodafone gesehen, dass das nicht so gut funktioniert.
Was war da genau los?
Na, es gab von Vodafone so eine Marketing-Kampagne, wo sie sich Blogger vor den Kahn spannen wollten. Das ist so ein bisschen daneben gegangen, die fanden das nicht so lustig.
Ah, es gibt diese Werbekampagne immer noch zu sehen, hat mir jemand erzählt, aber jetzt nur noch ohne Blogger. Also ganz ohne die ganzen bekannten Blogger. Es gibt irgendwie jeden Typ, der vom hoch raus springt und sich selbst fotografiert, der ist noch zu sehen, aber die ganzen Blogger... Nein, eben nicht. Das heißt, ich sag immer unbekannter. Tim will uns noch was zur Netzneutralität erzählen, die er erlebt hat.
Hallo, guten Abend. Ja, also erst mal bin ich auch auf jeden Fall für Informationsfreiheit, freies Internet. Und im Allgemeinen, muss ich sagen, finde ich das schon beängstigend, wie sich das halt alles entwickelt. So mein halt Internetanbieter... Ich weiß nicht, wie ich Namen nennen darf.
Wenn du jetzt also nicht anfängst, die Tarife anzupreisen...
Nein, nein, es geht jetzt zum Beispiel darum, ich hatte mir in meiner Wohnung halt einen Handysanschluss geholt und hab mich dann gefreut, schließe das an und merke, verdammt, ich komme mit meinem iPhone gar nicht ins Netz. Und dann hab ich gemerkt, ich bin da nicht ziemlich beschnitten dabei und dabei. Hab mir das zwar im Endeffekt selber zurechtgebastelt und hatte dann so mein freies Internet zu Hause mit meinen Geräten nicht benutzen wollte.
Und du kamst mit dem iPhone nicht in dein Netz über Alice?
Nein, es gab so ein Sphiron-Modem und dafür musste man auf jeden Fall PPOE anwenden, um halt reinzukommen. Also es war auf jeden Fall, musste man halt, musste man sich halt direkt mit den Daten einführen, das konnte das iPhone halt damals nicht.
Ach, du hattest keinen Router davor stehen gehabt, verstehe ich.
Nee, ich hab's mir nachher gesagt. Ich hab's von Alice gekriegt so und ich dachte halt, ich kann so frei los surfen. Auf jeden Fall war ich da halt auch schon gebremst mit der Informationsfreiheit, aber es wird halt auf vielen Fronten, finde ich, gekämpft.
Z.
B wenn man bei B-Pod kaufen will, ist wieder ein Content angeboten, den man dann nicht kaufen kann, weil man nicht aus den USA kommt. Oder man surft halt rum und guckt halt einfach mal aus Interesse beim BKA, ob man bei dem Heißgesuchten dabei ist und wird dann beschattet, wie sich das dann später rausgestellt hat. Oder z. B wenn man bei A-Kor ist, dass dann halt YouPorn gesperrt wird.
Bei A-Kor?
Das war mal. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch aktuell ist, aber es wurden halt so einige Porno-Contents und sonstige Sachen gesperrt. Oder jetzt aktuell, ich weiß jetzt nicht, war das Yahoo? Ich glaube, Yahoo, das kann man bei Wikileaks nachgucken. Da wurden halt sehr merkwürdige Inhalte gesperrt, halt auch Haise-Artikel und sonstiges. Und ich finde, wenn man sich das halt alles in groben so anguckt, dann auch mit den Netzsperren muss man eigentlich schon ganz genau aufpassen, was man anklickt. Wenn ich mir dann vorstelle, dass ich einen Freund von mir einfach eine Tiny-Ul-Schecke mit irgendeiner Porno-Seite, die jetzt vielleicht gerade auf dem Index, oder was weiß ich, was steht aus Spaß, und der klickt da raus, dann hat er halt eher gleich den Salat an der Haken.
Okay, jetzt sind wir aber schon wieder bei, also gehört das noch zum Thema, so richtig?
Ja, es ging jetzt natürlich nicht um die Inhalte. Es ging im Endeffekt eigentlich nur darum, dass man sich eigentlich ziemlich genau Gedanken machen muss, was man mittlerweile anklicken soll. Ich nutze das Internet schon ziemlich lange und habe da früher immer sehr frei rumgeklickt und mir angeguckt, was ich wollte und runtergeladen.
Würdest du denn für ein Internet sozusagen, wo du einfach machen könntest, was du wolltest, und ganz sicher wäre es niemand guckt drauf, würdest du da mehr zahlen?
Ich finde das Recht auf Information, das ist ein Recht, das jeder haben sollte, und ich finde nicht, warum ich das besonders vergüten lassen sollte. Das wäre, ich weiß auch nicht, warum sollte ich für die Wahrheit mehr Geld zahlen?
Aber dann sozusagen wirst du ja quasi im Zeitwitzfall nicht mehr ins Netz gehen?
Ne, darauf kann ich nicht verzichten.
Okay, ich glaube, Tim steht da noch eine eher schwierige Zeit bevor, weil er nicht mehr Geld zahlen will, was vielleicht kommt, aber trotzdem unbedingt im Internet bleiben muss. Wir sind gespannt, wie das ausgeht. Bernd wollte auch noch was zur Netzneutralität erzählen, und zwar im besonderen Fall von Voice over IP.
Hallo, Bernd. Hallo, erstmal piratische Grüße aus Berlin. Es geht darum, dass es gab ja in den Schlagzeilen so was, dass dementsprechend T-Mobile und ich glaube O2 oder Vodafone, eins von beiden, die Voice over IP-Leitung, wenn man dementsprechend das UMTS nutzt, sich einfach wegsperrt oder die Ports sperrt oder so.
Das haben wir am Anfang der Sendung ja schon darüber diskutiert.
Das heißt jetzt aber nicht unbedingt, dass wir es nicht normal machen können. Okay, also es geht darum, dass wir sagen, wenn man Internet auf dem Handy hat, dass man dann keinen Voice over IP mehr machen darf. Aber das ist doch eigentlich verständlich, oder?
Oder zumindest eingeschränkt. Na ja, ich sag mal so, es ist eigentlich eine frei... Man bezahlt ja im Endeffekt dasselbe wie auf einer Festnetzleitung. Ja, oder teurer dementsprechend und kann gewisse Dienste nicht nutzen. Und ich bin der Meinung, das zählt einfach nicht als Netzneutralität, weil...
Na ja, aber jetzt verkaufen die Anbieter ja auch kein neutrales Netz, sondern die Anbieter sagen ganz klar, pass auf, wir verkaufen Internet auf dem Handy ohne Voice over IP und ohne Instant Messaging.
Ja, aber komischerweise andere Anbieter, z. B ich bin bei Plus, denen ist es dann mal so scheißegal.
Das ist dann der Punkt, wo du als Nutzer sozusagen mit deinem Geldbeutel abstimmen kannst und sagen, von dem Anbieter ist mir bekannt, die haben Netzneutralität, gebe ich mein Geld bei denen aus. Das ist das, was ich hoffe, dass in den Köpfen der Nutzer in Zukunft ein bisschen sich manifestiert, dass man sich auch anguckt, wie hält mein Anbieter das mit der Netzneutralität und sich dann da entsprechend entscheidet.
Ja, weil ich bin der Meinung, das sollte man einfühlen, dass dementsprechend alle Nutzer diese Inrichter haben.
Der Gedanke von Nimla ist natürlich, dass wenn die Leute darauf achten, dann werden die Provider immer weniger, die können sich das einfach nicht mehr leisten, nicht neutral zu sein.
Aber es gibt ja den Einen zu sagen, wir machen das gesetzlich, wie die Bundesnetzagentur sagt, Netzneutralität muss gewährt bleiben, wir sollten vielleicht mal eine Regelung finden. Aber es gibt ja andere Leute, die sagen, lasst es doch einfach den Markt regeln. Es wird immer irgendeinen Internetanbieter geben, der sagt, hier bei mir kriegt ihr das Netz ungefiltert und der wird dann schon so viele Leute ziehen, dass sie das irgendwann von selbst erledigt haben.
Ja, weil der Trend geht ja im Endeffekt dahin, dass dementsprechend das Internet nur noch meist mobile benutzt wird.
Naja, aber wie du gerade sagst, es gibt schon Anbieter, wo das geht, wo man trotzdem Skype nutzen kann und Voice-over-IP und was auch immer. Da wird sich das schon irgendwie der Zeit nach durchsetzen. Reicht das dann nicht, wenn man jetzt den Markt selber klären lässt? Ok, Bernd haben wir überzeugt, das geht alles klar. Ja, ich habe einfach auch ein bisschen zufrieden, auf jeden Fall. Wie seht ihr das? Reicht das, dass man den Markt das überlässt und sagt, pass auf, mach halt einfach so und Netzneutqualität wird schon früher oder später kommen, weil es einfach das bessere Produkt ist?
Ich weiß nicht, der Markt hat eigentlich bei so kritischer Infrastruktur immer ziemlich wenig Gutes geschaffen und meistens musste es die eine oder andere Art der Kontrolle des Staats geben, z. B durch die Bundesnetzagentur, die dort Auflagen auferlegt hat. Das sieht man an den roaming-Preisen, z. B hat der Markt auch in Europa das einfach nicht reguliert, dass es billig geworden ist, bis der Staat interveniert hat, weil er meinte, dass innerhalb der EU man nicht für das Übertreten an der Grenze beim Telefonieren bestraft werden soll und vorher haben einfach in so einem großen Kartell die Telefonieanbieter einfach das Geld gemolken, wo es ging.
Das Spannende wiederum ist dann aber auch, dass es von der Ale of Men mit so einem kleinen GSM-Anbieter gibt, der inzwischen prepaid SIM-Karten anbietet mit kostenfreiem Incoming-Roaming. Also das ist schon eine Frage der sanften Regulierung an der Stelle.
Also man muss glaube ich auf allen Ebenen arbeiten. Also natürlich ist es gut, wenn die Leute ein bisschen drauf achten und nicht gerade zu so einem Zensurprovider oder was auch immer gehen, sondern eben einen anderen dann wählen. Aber das alleine reicht natürlich nicht. Also es ist auch wichtig, dass man eben politisch aktiv ist und sagt, also wir wollen Netzneutralität. Also das muss einfach auch mal eine Forderung sein und nicht sagen, das wird der Markt schon irgendwie hinbekommen, denn der Markt wird vielleicht noch ganz andere Dinge hinbekommen und immer mehr irgendwie Sachen extra bezahlbar machen oder so. Also da würde ich wirklich nicht auf den Markt vertrauen. Aber ich würde mich auch nicht auf den Staat verlassen. Also der Staat wird es nicht regeln.
Müssen wir dann vielleicht einfach alle selber unser eigener Internet-Provider werden?
Das ist eben das Problem. Der Markt, was Internetzugang angeht, ist aufgeteilt auf einige wenige Anbieter, die sich da ziemlich viel rausnehmen können, weil sie einen großen Kundenstamm haben. Also in der Tat schon problematisch. Es ist kein Dutzend Internet-Anbieter, was 90 Prozent der Leute bedient. Und da einen Nischen-ISP in einer nicht netzneutralen Landschaft hinzustellen, das ist deutlich aufwendig. Also da ist schon die freundliche regulierende Kraft gefragt, die großen Anbieter mal so ein bisschen Richtung Netzneutralität zu stubsen.
Alles klar, also der Markt eine wird es anscheinend nicht richten. Wie das funktionieren kann, ob es vielleicht eine Regulierungsidee ist, das werden wir gleich besprechen, z. B mit Markus, der hier angerufen hat. Ihr könnt auch noch anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110, denn nach den Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr, die es dann gleich geben wird, reden wir noch eine halbe Stunde über Netzneutralität und vorher geben wir uns eine kleine Pause und erfreuen den Chat zur Sendung, den ihr auf fritz.de findet, wenn ihr da klickt, etwas Musik. Und die kommt von Entertainment for the Brain Net und zwar im Kraftfutter Mischwerk Remix Run.
Immer noch laut, immer noch englisch und immer noch alles andere als tot.
Präsentiert von Prince.
Nachrichten.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Nach dem schweren Erdbeben vor der Insel Sumatra läuft die Hilfe für die Opfer an. Erste Mitarbeiter internationaler Organisationen sind im Einsatz, um Nothilfe zu leisten, teilte die Caritas mit. Einen Tag nach dem Seebeben im Südpazifik war das Erdbeben mit einer Stärke von 7, 6 auf der Richterskala auf den Westen der indonesischen Insel getroffen. Bisher sind mindestens 75 Menschen tot geborgen worden. Behörden befürchten aber tausende Opfer unter den Trümmern, weil viele Häuser eingestürzt sind. Die Zahl der Toten durch den Tsunami im Südpazifik gestern Abend wird inzwischen mit mehr als 120 angegeben. In Stuttgart wurde heute darüber beraten, wie Amokläufe an Schulen in Zukunft verhindert werden können. Ein Expertenteam hatte Vorschläge erarbeitet, wie Schulen sicherer gemacht werden sollen. Die Fachleute empfehlen zum Beispiel ein spezielles Türsystem für Klassenzimmer, bei dem sich im Ernstfall die Tür nur noch von innen öffnen lässt. Für Jugendliche wurde außerdem ein generelles Verbot von sogenannten Killerspielen vorgeschlagen. Ob die rund 80 Vorschläge auch umgesetzt werden, ist aber noch nicht klar. Bundestagsabgeordnete müssen komplett offenlegen, was sie nebenbei verdienen. Das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig entschieden und Klagen der SPD-Politiker Schili und Gröning abgewiesen. Sie hatten sich dagegen gewährt, dass Bundestagspräsident Lammert Honorare aus ihren Anwaltstätigkeiten auf Euro und Cent genau wissen wollte. Die Richter erklärten dies jedoch für rechtens. In der Fußball-Champions League hat Bayern München am Abend gegen Juventus Turin 0 zu 0 unentschieden gespielt. Außerdem unterlag Meister Wolfsburg bei Manchester United 1 zu 2. Heute Nacht ab und zu Regen bei tiefstwährenden zwischen 12 und 8 Grad. Am Tag dann erst viele Wolken und auch ein bisschen Regen. Nachmittags lockert dann etwas auf. Es sind aber einzelne Schauer möglich, das ganze bei Höchstwerten zwischen 13 und 15 Grad. A12 Frankfurt Oder Richtung Berlin zwischen Storke und Friedersdorf gefahrt durch ein defektes Fahrzeug auf der rechten Spur. Und A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Mainburg und Pritzwalk ist die Richtungsfahrbahn nach einem Unfall mit LKW gesperrt, da bitte auch vorsichtig ans Stau an, der heranfahren. Sonst überall. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz rund um Spremberg.
Mit Markus Richter im Chaos Radio und deswegen natürlich auch dem Chaos Computer Club. Ja, Gott, es wird Zeit, dass es vorbei ist. Aber eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch. Chaos Computer Club, heute in Gestalt von Erdgeist, Maha und Nibbler. Es geht um Netzneutralität, also kurz gesagt um Erdgeist was?
Um ein Netz, was sich dir gegenüber neutral verhält und den Daten, die du von dem Gesprächspartner abholen möchtest.
Das heißt, das Internet funktioniert so, dass alles das rauskommt, was man einfach so haben will. Aber das sehen manche Leute anders, z. Internet-Service-Provider. Also die Leute, die für euch das Internet besorgen, die denken nämlich, wenn man bestimmte Sachen langsamer macht oder gleich ganz verbietet, haben wir weniger Ärger damit. Dann können wir mehr Geld scheffeln und vielleicht den Leuten noch extra Kohle abknöpfen, wenn wir ihn doch wieder zur Verfügung stellen. Jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit schon drüber geredet, ob es jetzt ein freies Netz geben muss oder vielleicht doch eins, was total kontrolliert ist oder so ein Zwischending. Und Markus hat angerufen, was sie auch noch machen können, 031 70 97 110 und hat eine Idee, wie wir das Netz regulieren könnten. Hallo Markus.
Hallo.
So, du hast eine Regulierungsidee.
Äh, ich hab eigentlich eher was zum Quality of Service noch mal. Eine Idee, wie man das umsetzen könnte, weil die ISPs ja das immer so vorschieben, ja wir müssen hier unser Voice-over-IP da schnell über die Leitung kriegen und deshalb dürft ihr kein Torrent machen. So, und wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, man kriegt halt seine Leitung, also ich für 30 Euro im Monat und kriegt da, was weiß ich, so zwei oder zwei Slots, so Quality of Service-Slots, was ich eingestuft habe, jeweils zwei in Hochmittel und Niedrig, so und dann kann man eben da seine Dienste, die man selber so gerade so braucht, wichtig da rein sortieren.
Okay, du sagst also sagen, der Service Provider gibt uns eine bestimmte Anzahl an Anwendungen, die wir sagen können, okay, du bist jetzt wichtig.
Genau, dass er sagt, okay, ich brauche jetzt, ich will jetzt spielen, will super schnell beide hier spielen und da kann ich eben sagen, okay, jetzt ist eben Spiel XY ganz oben auf der Liste, das muss jetzt ganz flink gehen. Und weil ich da eben in der Zeit nicht telefonieren will oder so, kann ich eben sagen, okay, alles, was weiß, wobei viel praktik ist, in die Mitte oder ganz runter oder je nachdem.
Ist es überhaupt praktikabel und oder vorstellbar?
Das ist im Prinzip Quality of Service, dass man dann seine Pakete ranschreibt, du bist wichtig, du bist nicht so wichtig, du bist überhaupt nicht wichtig. Also das ist durchaus was, was man realisieren kann, die Internet Service Provider beachten, nur diese Markierungen an den Paketen nicht.
Das ist ja die Frage sozusagen, wenn man das könnte, dann wäre die Frage so, ich sitze zu Hause und denke so, ich habe diese drei Gigabyte an Zerteporn, den ich jetzt unbedingt runterladen muss, und zwar in den nächsten fünf Minuten, ich schreibe an alle meine Pakete ran, das ist total wichtig. Wie will man denn sowas dann verhindern? Oder gar nicht?
Dann werden sie halt alle gleich behandelt.
Dann ist man aber sozusagen wieder am Anfang.
Dann ist man wieder am Anfang.
Das heißt, der Vorschlag, den Markus gemacht hat, funktioniert eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Nein, der funktioniert nur auf dem Stück der Leitung, was zu dir nach Hause geht und mehr oder weniger dann nach draußen. Aber das Geheimnis an dieser Paketklassifizierung, an dieser Packet-Inspection, ist ja, dass man den Datenverkehr wirklich in Tiefen analysiert. Dass man wirklich in die Pakete reinguckt und sagt, das ist der Dienst, das ist der Dienst. Und ja, das ist dann eben viel in der Netzneutralität, wenn man auf der Basis dessen, was da drin ist und wie man das...
Okay, naja, also sagen, da geht es um zwei verschiedene Sachen. Das heißt, Markus meint, wir machen es so, dass wir dem Provider sagen können, hier, mach mal bitte jetzt dieses eine Ding schneller. Und was du meinst, ist ja der Provider entscheidet für mich, was schneller ist und nicht.
Genau, das ist der Unterschied.
Aber sozusagen, und die Idee, die Markus hatte, ist aber demzufolge nicht durchsetzbar.
Nicht so richtig, ne?
Nicht so richtig. Okay, sorry Markus, da musst du dir nochmal was anderes ausdenken. Vielleicht hat Jan noch eine Idee, wie reguliert werden kann. Hallo Jan.
Hallo, ja, ich rufe vom iPhone aus an.
Das tut mir aber leid.
Und da ist man ja mit einigen Einschränkungen beim Netzzugang vertraut, die vielleicht jetzt nicht im Kern die Netzneutralität betreffen, aber damit verwandt sind. Und ich habe bisher so den Eindruck, wir sind uns ja alle einig, dass Netzneutralität was ganz Tolles ist. Aber die eigentliche Frage, und die ist in der Sendung, finde ich, ist ja noch nicht beantwortet worden, ist doch, wie gehen wir jetzt damit politisch um? Also am Sonntag waren ja Bundestagswahlen und da sind ja eher marktliberale Kräfte gewählt worden. Ja, und konkret meine Frage wäre, wer zum einen an die Vertreter des Chaos Computer Clubs was schlagen die denn eigentlich vor? Weil ich mich einfach persönlich frage, wie viel Regulierungen brauchen wir? Brauchen wir also, wenn ich mal meinen iPhone-Tarif nehme, als informierter Kunde weiß ich ja irgendwie, was da auf mich zukommt, kommt, dass da bestimmte Dinge, Stichwort Tethering ist eben schon gefallen, nicht funktionieren oder eingeschränkt funktionieren oder Extra-Kosten. Also mein Eindruck persönlich ist, dass es da eigentlich eher am mündigen Konsumenten scheitert, der einfach teilweise sich gar nicht auskennt und nicht weiß, dass bestimmte Dienste beispielsweise eingeschränkt werden können und wir nicht unbedingt eine ganz starke Regulierung brauchen, die jetzt die Netzneutralität gesetzlich vorschreibt.
Aber du sagst keine Regulierung?
Ich sage nicht keine Regulierung, aber ich mache mich ganz ehrlich, wie viel Regulierung ist nötig. Und ich bin gewiss kein FDP-Vertreter, sondern sogar Fördermitglied im Chaos Computer Club. Das kann ich allen Hörern mir auch empfehlen. Aber trotzdem, was für Regulierung ist eigentlich nötig? Also brauchen wir, reicht es aus, vielleicht irgendwie Backbones freizuhalten, also dargesetzlich zu regeln, dass das Netz jetzt in der Zugang neutral sein muss. Aber ist es nicht eigentlich sogar vielleicht im Sinne der Kunden, also verbraucherfreundlich zu sagen, naja, dass es eben Tarife gibt, in denen mein Netzzugang in irgendeiner Art und Weise eingeschränkt ist, aber dafür sind die dann eben billiger, weil der Markt das einfach entsprechend, also weil die Anbieter damit eben dann auch niedrigere Kosten haben.
Also könnte man es zusammenfassen mit, du möchtest Lida, kann alles haben, wenn er will, aber es ist durchaus okay, wenn andere Sachen auch angeboten werden.
Ja, möglicherweise. Also ich persönlich möchte eigentlich schon einen freien Netzzugang haben, also natürlich ärgert mich das, dass ich bei meinem iPhone irgendwie Skype nicht über andere Dienste, nicht über das Mobilfunknetz nutzen kann, aber ich habe ja als Kunde auch die Wahl und kann auch sagen, ich kaufe mir eben kein iPhone oder ich kaufe mir entsprechend lieber bei E+, irgendeinen Datentarif, der das möglich macht. Aber das setzt natürlich auch voraus, dass die Verbraucher entsprechend informiert sind.
An der Stelle zitiere ich vielleicht gerne eine Dame von der Bundesnetzagentur, das war heute ein Haise-Artikel, vielleicht hilft hier die Drohung mit einem inkompetenten Regulierer, um die Parteien an den Verhandlungstisch zurückzubringen. Das ist eigentlich schön formuliert, dass da der sanfte Druck sozusagen für eine Diskussion sorgt, die sei es zwischen den Anbietern, sei es zwischen Anbietern und Interessensträgern auf verschiedenen Seiten. Also es ist einfach ein Thema, was diskutiert werden muss, wo man nicht nur die Internet-Service-Provider an einem Tisch hat, sondern eben auch die Nutzer.
Jetzt aber, er hat sozusagen ja noch eine ganz konkrete Frage gehabt. Chaos Computer Club, wie viel Regulierung wollt ihr haben?
Na, vor der Regulierung steht erstmal der mündige Bürger. Es gibt in Deutschland einfach zur Netzneutralität noch keine gesellschaftliche Debatte. Da wird einfach mal für gegeben genommen, wie du am Anfang meintest, dass da das Internet schon aus der Wand kommt und dahinter ist dann diese schöne Blümchenwiese, auf der man rumtollen und die Daten einsammeln kann. Aber wer dort die Spieler sind, das verstehen die meisten Leute nicht. Und bevor es dort nicht die gesellschaftliche Debatte gibt, ist es schwer dort auch wieder bevormundend Forderungen aufzustellen. Also es muss am Ende eine Regulierung geben, das haben wir in anderen Bereichen gesehen. Aber bevor das Bewusstsein nicht geschärft ist, auch in der Öffentlichkeit, dass dort diese Neutralität eigentlich ein ziemlich wichtiges Gut ist und wie viel man bereit ist von dieser Neutralität für bestimmte Bequemlichkeit oder Geschwindigkeit in seinem Netz aufzugeben, das sollte dann später auch der Bürger oder Kunde in dem Fall selber entscheiden.
Also Punkt Nr. 1, die Leute sollen sich gefälligst informieren.
Wir brauchen sozusagen das Ökobewusstsein, mal war das da gekommen, das brauchen wir in Datenbewusstsein.
Wow, ich glaube, das ist ja schon wieder fast ein Thema für ein eigenes Chaosradio. Das Datenbewusstsein. Aber okay, also natürlich, ja, so sagen wir, wenn man politische Vorwürfe stellen will, brauchen wir noch viele Leute, aber habt ihr sozusagen trotzdem keinen Plan, wo es hingehen soll?
Das ist wirklich schwer, man, wir wissen halt, was wir nicht wollen. Es gibt schon so ein Internet, wo man sich das mal angucken kann, wie es aussieht, wenn es oll ist. Und es ist, viele Leute arbeiten inzwischen in Firmen, wo ihr ISP eigentlich ihr Arbeitgeber ist. D h. wo sie am Rechner rangesetzt werden, dort auch privat surfen können, aber der Arbeitgeber selber einen ziemlich dicken Daumen drauf hat, was da an Internet ankommt und was nicht. Oh, der Markus kennt das hier vom Stritz. Und da sieht man, dass der ISP dort eine ziemlich strikte Agenda hat. Der will sich viel Ärger vermeiden, der will viel Kosten sparen und der stellt eigentlich das Internet den Mitarbeitern als Werkzeug zu erledigen von beruflichen Aufgaben zur Verfügung und räumt dann, weil das irgendwie so allgemein so ist, dann auch für private Nutzung so ein bisschen E-Mail, so ein bisschen Nachrichtenseiten klicken, räumt dann dem Mitarbeiter ein, dieses Internet auch privat zu nutzen. Aber dieses Internet ist schon krass reguliert und auch zensiert. Und dort sieht man dann, wie es in eine Richtung gehen kann, wo dann wirklich Adminen sich mal austoben können und beschränken, was da der Nutzer macht.
Also die Leute, die sich jetzt rüber informieren, sollen sich einfach mal vorstellen, das ganze Internet sehe so aus wie bei euch auf Arbeit. Sie haben eine unzulängliche Seite. Sie haben eine mit falschen Inhalten gesperrte Seite angesurft. Bitte geben Sie Ihre Nutzerdaten ein, wenn Sie wirklich darauf zugreifen wollen. Das ist die Seite, die ich mal gesehen habe. Nicht hier woanders.
Na, es gibt irgendwie Entwicklungen mit dem elektronischen Personalausweis. Da muss man ganz toll aufpassen, dass nicht demnächst irgendwann, wenn das mit der Netzzensur da mal überhand nimmt, dass man dann, bevor man ins Internet darf, dort seinen Ehepaar irgendwo in die Tastatur legt und dann erst bestimmte Seiten freigeschaltet bekommt.
Also das ist das Worst-Case-Szenario, die schlimmste Situation, die ihr euch ausdenken könnt, was Netzneutralität angeht. Da soll es auf jeden Fall nicht hingehen.
Schlimmer geht natürlich immer, aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall. Okay, Jan, hat das irgendwie deine Frage beantwortet?
Ich bin jetzt auf der Straße und verkehre im Hintergrund. Insofern, dass ich jetzt weiß, dass auch der CCC noch nicht so richtig eine Position dazu hat, aber ich bin ja auch der Meinung, dass das Hauptmang oder nicht, dass unsere Politiker noch nicht in diesen Angelegenheiten Bescheid wissen.
Also wäre mein Vorschlag, alle Bürger informieren sich selbst und wenn sie sich alle informiert haben, informieren sie dann mal die Politiker, die auch endlich Bescheid wissen. Ich hoffe, das hilft dann. So, dann haben wir noch den Markus, das ist heute der Letzte, den ich fragen muss. Die waren erstaunlich große Anzahl an Markusen heute. Den letzte, den ich fragen will, frei ist Netz, ja oder nein?
Ja, ich bin natürlich für frei ist Netz. Aber was ein großes Problem für mich ist, ich bin so ein Dau quasi. Also da habe ich doch kein Problem, das zu sagen. Vielleicht ein Semi-Dau, weil mir die ein oder anderen Fachtermini schon geläufig sind.
Also für die, die jetzt nicht mal wissen, was ein Dau ist, kannst du die Abkürzung nochmal kurz erläutern?
Das schlimmste anzunehmender User. Also ich habe wirklich, wenn ich habe Freunde, die studieren Informatik oder sind Programmierer oder sonst was, wenn die sich untereinander unterhalten über irgendwelche Sachen, dann höre ich öfter auch einfach nur noch 11001 ein. Und da ist halt eben mein Problem. Ich kriege zwar schon viel mit und das interessiert mich ja auch viel. Also gerade, ich bin da auch über meine Kumpels dann halt eben ans Chaosradio und Chaosradio Express angekommen. Und als das dann so mit den Netzsperren anfing etc. da habe ich dann noch mal ein bisschen interessiert dazu gehört und habe auch mal viel nachgesurft. Das Problem ist, dass man unendlich viel Zeit investieren muss, um sich mal schlau zu machen. Ich glaube, es würden sich viel mehr Leute dafür interessieren, wenn sie wirklich mit einem kurzen Zeitaufwand sich über das Thema informieren können. Ich mache jetzt gerade eine Ausbildung zum Heilherzjungslehrer. Ich habe 90% Frauen in Akters. Wenn ich denen jetzt sage, euer Content, den ihr da kriegt, da kann euer Zugangsprovider machen mit, was er will. Der kann euch eben auch mal was nicht zeigen. Dann sagen die, naja, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Das ist eben die Sache.
Dann musst du da hinten nach plastischen Beispielen suchen, dass die konkurrierende Fiseurseite dann einfach nicht mehr aufzurufen ist.
Ja, ja, so was halt eben. Das ist eben die Sache. Plastische Beispiele sind immer gut, aber es wäre quasi so ein Dauch-Wiki. Das wäre echt so göttlich. Dann kann man einfach nur sagen, ja, ihr schaut einfach mal auf der Seite nach, die zeigen euch das jetzt mal plastisch. Ich hab's schon mal bei meiner Mutter mehr oder weniger geschafft, ich hab gesagt, hier, hört ihr einfach mal den Podcast an zum Thema Netzsperren. Der ist einfach ziemlich gut beschrieben. Da kann man schon selber so ein bisschen was raushören. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht von jedem immer verlangen, dass er sich so ein Podcast komplett durchhört, weil geht einfach nicht.
Man könnte aber auch als Gegenmeinung sagen, naja, es ist aber so irgendwie, fast jeder kommt im Computer in Kontakt. Das ist einfach mal Bürgerpflicht, dass sie sich informieren.
Ja, Bürgerpflicht hin und her.
Du hast ja auch Verkehrserziehungsunterricht mitgemacht, oder? Damit du nicht im Straßenverkehr überfahren wirst, wenn du da einfach nicht weißt, welche Frauen.
Jaja, aber gut, denn es gibt ja so gesehen kein Verkehrserziehungsunterricht fürs Internet. Da würde ich mich ja auch mal im Vorredner anschließen. Es gibt halt eben für alles schon irgendwelche Regeln etc. Und was ist mit dem, klar, mündige Bürger sollte es geben, deshalb informiere ich mich ja auch erstmal selber. Aber irgendwann hört auch die Motivation auf, sich selbst zu informieren, wenn man wirklich erstmal eine Menge an Wissen mitbringen muss, um da in dieses ganze Thema einzusteigen.
Na gut, aber wir können sagen, es ist ja quasi das Angebot, das hier auch gerade stattfindet, also das Chaosradio z. Du sagst ja von dir, du bist nicht so doll fit. Hast du die Sendung heute gehört?
Ja, ich habe sie jetzt komplett verfolgt. Zumal ich auch relativ lange bei euch in der Warteschlange hingekommen bin.
Und hast du jetzt die Sache mitbekommen, um es heute ging?
Ja natürlich, das war mir auch schon vorher gelaufen. Ich bin zufällig auch da drauf gestolpert, weil ich folge im Twitter dem Piraten NRW. Und da hat jemand verlinkt, ein Artikel von ZDNet, wo geschrieben wird, dass Wodafone über UMTS gewisse Inhalte sperrt oder dann auch eigene Inhalte anfeicht. Also schon Netzsperre in klein als Probelauf.
Du bist jetzt jemand, der nicht den Superplan hat, aber heute zugehört hat, interessiert, dass es verstanden hat. Wenn du es jetzt wiederum für die Leute erklärst, die nicht mal das Interesse aufbringen zuzuhören, dann sind wir schon wieder einen Schritt weiter.
Ja, aber manchmal ist es eben schwer, so etwas zu formulieren. Und dann so einfach mal so, ich kann euch das jetzt gerade nicht erklären, aber wenn es euch wirklich interessiert, dann guckt mal da und danach. Da ist es wirklich super beschrieben. Habe ich z. B wurde vorhin mal gerade genannt, auch irgendwie in der Sendung dieses OTR-Zeug. Habe ich vorher auch keine Ahnung von mir. Dann hier war mal ein Java-Account hier über Java CCCD angelegt und dann auch das Plugin in Pitkin reingehauen, weil da es einfach ein super Tutorial war. Da musste ich eigentlich quasi nur ablesen. Und das kann jeder Mensch.
Da hast du diesen Blog-Artikel gelesen in Chitola?
Genau, da habe ich diesen Blog-Artikel gelesen, an dem bin ich auch über einen Kumpel gekommen, der eben auch ein bisschen mehr Plan davon hat. Und der sagte, das ist super einfach. Guckt da drauf und das wirst du auf jeden Fall verstehen. Und sowas meinte ich eben so. Für da ist wirklich einfach so ein Wiki. Leute, ihr seid guckt drauf und ihr versteht, was eigentlich gerade mit euch passiert.
Alles klar, hoffen wir, dass das irgendwann sozusagen Realität wird. Aber es liegt natürlich ein bisschen an euch. Es gibt ja sozusagen jede Menge Hörer, die das Chaos-Radio hören, die sehr wohl fit sind und sehr wohl wissen, was abgeht, auch weit aus mehr, als wir heute geredet wurden. Und Markus, das ist glaube ich so eine Aufforderung, auch an die. Ich führ euch mal zusammen und erklär es auch denen, die es einfach noch nicht wissen. Wir hatten außerdem noch zwei Fragen aus dem Chat.
Genau, die würde ich einfach mal so relayen. Vielleicht macht Nibler, die ja beantworten, woher weiß man eigentlich überhaupt, dass man zu Hause ungefiltertes Internet hat.
Das ist relativ schwer. Sowas fällt einem natürlich erst auf, wenn es zu spät ist. Ja, kann man so nicht sagen. Das ist das Problem an dieser Netzneutralität, dass es wirklich sehr subtil ist. Dass man jetzt nicht wirklich weiß, ist die Seite, wo man da gerade zugreifen möchte, ist das Ding einfach so langsam, ist das für alle langsam, oder ist das nur für mich langsam, oder hat da mein Anbieter bestimmte Interessen.
Es gab vor zwei oder drei Jahren die große Diskussion um die Bundestrojane und die Art und Weise, wie diese in die Rechner der Beschuldigten dort reingebracht werden sollten. Da war eins der Möglichkeiten, während man an seinem hermischen Windows-PC sich hier so ein Programm runterlädt, einfach heimlich das Programm auszutauschen gegen irgendetwas anderes, was dann von Schäuble persönlich kommt. Dagegen gab es so ein Projekt, dass man alle ausführbaren Dateien, die man sich aus dem Internet runterlädt, oder dort eine Prüfsumme gegen einen dezentralen Dienst angucken kann. Dass es vielleicht genau ein Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk gibt, in dem man die Netzneutralität durch Vergleich von die Seite sieht aber so aus, wenn ich von hier klicke und da stehen plötzlich auf der Nachrichtenseite andere Nachrichten drauf, wenn ich keine Ahnung vom Bild gesponsert bin im Internet.
Aber dazu brauche ich ja schon mal den Verdacht, dass was nicht in Ordnung ist.
Ja, was heißt denn nicht in Ordnung? Also bei der nicht in Ordnung impliziert ja immer, dass da irgendwie was Böses passiert. Und mein Anliegen war ja heute gewesen, dass der Verlust der Netzneutralität ja immer irgendwie so ein zweischneidiges Schwert ist. Auf der einen Seite möchte man irgendwie filtern, z. B wenn da Spam rausgefiltert wird, auf der anderen Seite möchte man nicht zensiert werden von irgendjemandem, der man nicht selber ist. Und diese Netzneutralität wird angeknabbert von allen Seiten, aus pragmatischen Gründen, aus finanziellen Gründen, aus politischen Gründen. Aber man soll sich dessen immer bewusst sein. Und deswegen will man wissen, dass da grad was nicht Neutrales passiert. Ob man es selber für schlimm findet oder nicht, muss man danach später für sich selbst entscheiden.
Du kannst irgendwie in den Supermarkt gehen, kannst dir Bio-Zeugs kaufen und weißt auch nicht wirklich, ob das von glücklichen Hühnern ist oder auch nicht.
Und da hatten wir noch eine Frage.
Genau, was mit der Netzneutralität im Licht der Pressefreiheit ist, habe ich ja auch grad angeschnitten, wenn man nämlich plötzlich im Supermarkt, neben der tollen Bild-Telefonkarte, jetzt irgendwie auch noch das Bild-Internet zu Hause bekommt und dann plötzlich irgendwie die linke Presse nicht mehr lesen kann oder irgendwie die linke Presse nur noch, wo Politiker-Namen durch andere Politiker-Namen ersetzt sind, lesen kann oder...
Aber das ist doch sozusagen eine Schreckensvision. Das ist doch nicht Realität.
Also bei uns in Deutschland.
Ich glaube, es gab da mal ein Kunstprojekt von so einem Studenten, der in seiner Universität genau so einen Filter installiert hat, wo einfach Politiker-Namen gegeneinander ausgetauscht worden sind und dann mal einen Tag nachgeguckt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es den Leuten auffallen würde, wenn es auf dem Spiegel passieren würde.
Okay, es ist also technisch möglich, aber wir gehen jetzt mal nicht davon aus, dass es schon um einen großen Master-Up gemacht wird. Oder haben wir im Prinzip jetzt doch eine andere Regierung, und sind nur die falschen Namen in den Nachrichten gewesen.
Wo habt ihr denn eure Wahlergebnisse her?
Aber in der Tat eine spannende Frage. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit auch darüber geredet, was möglich wäre. Und die Tendenz war eindeutig, dass sozusagen Netzneutralität gewünscht ist. Die Frage ist, was ist denn technisch überhaupt möglich? Da kann Niblad noch ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Was die Leute, die uns die Steckdose ins Loch in die Wand machen, wo das Internet rauskommt, was können die denn überhaupt?
Da hört man das Argument, das ist doch so viel Datenverkehr, das kann man sich doch gar nicht. Und Computer sind doch gar nicht so schnell. Um mal ein paar Zahlen zu nennen, so ein großes Backbone wie das, was in Magenta da draußen steht, die haben so zwischen 300 und 600 Gigabit Datenumsatz, also 300 und 600 Gigabit pro Sekunde. Das hört sich jetzt erstmal noch viel an, aber wenn man sich anguckt, was die Hardware heutzutage leistet, man kriegt in einem so einen Schrank problemlos die Packet Inspection Gerät, was so seine 30, 40 Gigabit macht, und da hat man dann nur noch 10 Stück davon. Dadurch, dass der Datenverkehr so schön verteilt ist, verteilt man halt, lass es zählen, dass es 20 sein, bundesweit. Das kann sich so ein Internet Service Provider, wenn er größer ist, leisten. Und das wird er sich auch, weil es einfach von den Einsparungen her entsprechend was bringt.
Wait, darf ich es nochmal zusammenfassend nachfragen? Es ist so, dass du sagst, ein Internet Service Provider kann theoretisch, also es ist technisch machbar, jedes einzelne Paket, das er überträgt, durchleuchten und wissen, was da drin stattfindet.
Nicht nur durchleuchten, sondern richtig tief durchleuchten und irgendwie selbst state halten und sich merken, was da gerade bei so einem einzelnen Kunden losgeht und kann sich dann nach Filterregeln auch sogar noch einzelne raussuchen, die im Rauschen dann ganz besonders auffallen, die kurz ausleiten und dann nochmal gesondert noch tiefer behandeln.
Okay, aber er kann auf jeden Fall erstmal angucken, wie teuer ist sowas? Also in welchen Größenordnungen bewegen wir uns da?
Also schon im sechsstelligen Bereich für so ein Gerät, aber das ist verglichen mit dem, also um es in eine Relation zu setzen. Das, was ein Internet-Service-Provider für seine Router ausgibt, das packt er einfach nochmal obendrauf und dann hat er nicht nur Router, sondern auch welche, die Pakete klassifizieren können. Also das ist für sie jetzt kein Hinderungsgrund.
Das ist keine Hexerei sozusagen. Weißt du denn auch?
Noch dazu argumentieren diese Hersteller von so Hardware damit, dass man das ja eh braucht, um bestimmte Gesetze einhalten zu können, wie Internet sperren usw. Und dadurch, dass es zu einer gefühlt notwendigen Sache wird, nehmen die Internet-Service-Provider das natürlich umso lieber an, um dann auch noch so ein bisschen den Zusatzbonus zu haben, dass sie ihre User ein bisschen unter Kontrolle haben.
Und wenn es ihnen vielleicht sogar vom Staat bezahlt wird, weil es ja ihre gesetzliche Verpflichtung ist, dort die Netzsperren durchzusetzen.
wir können davon ausgehen, dass Deutschland schon rumsteht? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Okay, möglich ist ja also schon die Netzbefangenheit, wie das Gegenstück von Netzneutralität heißt. Damit ist das Chaosradio fast schon wieder zu Ende. Das nächste gibt es, wie gewohnt, in einem Monat. Und zwischendurch könnt ihr euch die Zeit mit anderen Sachen vertreiben. Das wird Maha kurz nochmal sagen.
Ja genau, also wir können uns direkt schon sehen im realen Leben bei den Datenspuren jetzt am kommenden Wochenende. Und natürlich dann am 8. Oktober, Donnerstag, zum Datengarten. Da geht es halt um BitTorrent und was das politisch und technisch bedeutet. Also insbesondere da eben auch offene Systeme. Und dann nochmal am 22. Oktober, wo es um das soziale Web geht. Also da können wir uns dann direkt sehen. Und ich möchte noch hinzufügen, also Markus, du hast vorhin gesagt, der Chaos Computer Club weiß noch nicht so genau, was er will.
Das hab ich nicht gesagt, das hat Jan gesagt.
Also es ist schon so, dass wir schon für freie Netze antreten und natürlich gegen die Netzbefangenheit und gegen Netzzensur.
Okay, ich möchte noch eine Sache anfügen, die nichts mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu tun hat, aber auch ungefähr ins Thema passt. Vom 8. bis 11. Oktober ist das NetAudio Festival. Und da kommt auch der Folgen her, der euch jetzt gleich verabschieden wird und wird dort am Freitagabend live auflegen. Das ist der letzte Song, den ich heute spiele. Danach kommt Smith'n'Smart im Night Flight und werden euch wahrscheinlich so lange mit Mash-ups bearbeiten, bis euch die Ohren bluten. Vorher gibt es noch mal Trekkie Birthday mit Dragan Espenschied und Website, ein gutes Stück Nordcore. Ich sage Tschüss zu Erdgeistmacher und Nibbler. Und wie gesagt, wenn ihr das nächste Mal dabei sein wollt, in einem Monat ist es wieder so weit.